in terms of major paychecks for movie
stars the MCU got off to a relatively
modest starts since then though thanks
to sequel contracts bonuses and gross
percentages many of the MCU stars have
made serious Bank and some of them have
joined the ranks of the highest-paid
actors in the world here's a look at
some of the reported top earners Marvel
Studios has historically done its best
to save on upfront cost of production by
paying its new stars a relatively small
sum for starring in superhero films then
offering more significant pay in the
form of back-end compensation like
bonuses and box office percentages this
is how Robert Downey jr. went from
earning six figures for Ironman in 2008
to taking home 75 million dollars for
Avengers infinity war in 2018 still even
Marvel's upfront earnings for its stars
have grown along with the studio's box
office success and that shows when it
comes to stars like Chadwick Boseman
bozeman who debuted as Black Panther in
2016 s Captain America's Civil War got
his first solo superhero film in 2018
black panther was a worldwide phenomenon
and currently reigns as a tenth highest
grossing film of all time making it
Marvel's most successful solo superhero
movie effort Bozeman was reportedly paid
two million dollars to star in the film
which is an impressive number for his
first Marvel solo movie compared to what
the film ultimately earned though it
feels like Marvel got a bargain brie
Larson's 2019 debut in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe had a lot riding on
it and not just because it was an
attempt to introduce yet another sub
franchise into the Marvel Studios family
Captain Marvel starring Larson in the
title role was the studio's first female
led superhero film fans hoped it would
be another breakthrough film for
diversity in the genre much like black
panther was in early 2018 the film
ultimately took in 1.12 billion dollars
worldwide and Larson is set to be a
major piece of Marvel storytelling going
forward the effort paid off even before
we all knew what Captain Marvel would be
though Larsen who was already an Oscar
winner for her role in room when she was
cast in the MCU was looking for a payday
that was going to give her a solid
foundation particularly when it came to
pay equity with male co-stars to that
end her ultimate Captain Marvel payday
was reportedly five million dollars or
ten times what Robert Downey jr. made
upfront to star an Iron Man back in 2008
samuel l.jackson filmography is the
highest-grossing of any
around the planets at more than thirteen
point three billion dollars worldwide
thanks in no small part to his ability
to become a part of major franchises
even if he's not in a leading role
this happened with the Star Wars
prequels and it's happened again with
the MCU in which he's been appearing
ever since the post-credits scene of
iron man back in 2008 who the hell are
you Nick Fury director of shield I'm
here to talk to you about the Avenger
initiative 2019 alone finds Jackson
appearing in three different Marvel
films though his roles in the film's
range from sidekick to cameo that makes
his overall salary for the flicks very
heart pinned down but Jackson certainly
made an effort to keep on par with some
of the franchise's bigger stars for the
Avengers in 2012 he reportedly took home
somewhere between 4 to 6 million dollars
after bonuses came in and for Avengers
age of Ultron he was among the cast
members who reportedly went after at
least five million dollars upfront plus
even more once the film started to make
serious money there's no word on his
spider-man far from home payday just yet
but Jackson has said he'd happily keep
playing Nick Fury for as long as Marvel
will have him serves a lot of earning
potential left there before Mark Ruffalo
was in the picture Edward Norton played
the hawk Norton ultimately bowed out of
the MCU due to various creative
differences so when it came time to make
the Avengers Ruffalo was the only member
of the main team who hadn't already
appeared in some capacity in another MCU
flick
should I got paid up front banner that
could have put him at a disadvantage but
he mostly kept pace with his co-stars
Ruffalo reportedly joined the club of
actors including Chris Hemsworth Chris
Evans and Jeremy Renner who managed to
earn two to three million dollars for
the Avengers after bonuses and then also
became one of the team members who
pushed for a raise in the five million
dollar range for Avengers age of Ultron
there's no reliable reporting on what
came next for him in terms of pay for
Thor Ragnarok in the last two Avengers
movies but Ruffalo likely got his due
for continuing his wonderful work as dr.
Bruce Banner
Benedict Cumberbatch was already a
pop-culture fan favorite and Award
winner before he was tapped to play
surgeon turned sorcerer dr. strange a
bigger name means a bigger paycheck did
the MCU money guys deliver you bets for
his MCU debut in 2016 s Doctor Strange
Cumberbatch reportedly earned a little
more than three million dollars
that solo film plus his cameo appearance
in thor ragnarok and his supporting
roles in Avengers infinity war and
adventures endgame bumped his marvel
payday up to about five million dollars
by 2019 Cumberbatch's success in the MCU
so far is about to lead to even bigger
things according to the mirror the actor
is negotiating for a nearly 10 million
dollar payday for the upcoming Doctor
Strange sequel I come to bargain like
the other major phase 1 MCU stars Chris
Hemsworth had to settle for a relatively
low payday at first but as the films
grew in popularity his initial pay and
the bonuses he stood to earn continued
to climb though his third paycheck was
relatively small Hemsworth space swelled
by the time of the first Avengers film
earning him 2 to 3 million dollars with
various box office bonuses as the
sequels piled up so too did the higher
paychecks that deal reportedly shot up
to 5 million dollars up front plus
future bonuses for Avengers age of
Ultron and by the time the Infinity Saga
neared its end game Hemsworth payout had
swelled even more sources say he
collected something in the range of 15
to 20 million dollars for Thor Ragnarok
and took home similar paychecks for both
infinity war and endgame plus the finale
event game leaves plenty of room for
Hemsworth to keep earning Marvel money
in future films there's a remarkable
degree of symmetry to the Marvel careers
of Chris Evans and Chris Hemsworth at
least when it comes to the rise of their
respective salaries Evans like Hemsworth
arrived with a relatively low pay day
for Captain America the First Avenger
but things started to really pick up
when it came time to finally assemble
the team with the Avengers like
Hemsworth Evans reportedly earned a
final paycheck in the 2 to 3 million
dollar range for that film and then
started aiming even higher for sequels
Evans was also among the group of actors
who angled for a five million dollar
upfront paycheck for Avengers age of
Ultron and then came Captain America
Civil War Evans reportedly renegotiated
a payday of 15 million dollars for that
film and by the time the last two
Avengers flicks rolled around Evans was
like Hemsworth also aiming for a payday
in the 15 to 20 million dollar range
Scarlett Johansson is just now getting
her own Black Widow solo movie despite
being one of the MCS longest-serving
stars she first appeared in a supporting
role in Iron Man 2 then transitioned
into being the first and for a little
while the only
male member of the Avengers making her
an integral part of the MCU throughout
the Infinity Saga Johansson was an
established movie star before the MCU
kicked off so even her earliest Marvel
paydays were substantial she reportedly
earned somewhere in the neighborhood of
four to six million dollars for her work
on the Avengers after collecting various
box office bonuses on that film her
numbers have climbed since then but for
Johansson the best is yet to come
Black Widow will net her a reported
twenty million dollar payday for serving
as both star and producer when Iron Man
arrived in 2008 Robert Downey jr.
immediately hit a new level of stardom
Downey's initial pay for Iron Man was
rather small compared to where he ended
up but bonuses based on the film's
box-office gross help pad that number
outs then in the wake of the film's
success Downey and his rep started
renegotiating and the paychecks for The
Godfather of the MCU just kept gaining
more zeroes truth is
I am Iron Man Downey was ultimately able
to cut a deal with Marvel Studios by
which he collects a hefty back end
earnings percentage not just from Iron
Man solo films but from Avengers movies
the actual percentage is not publicly
known but it's reportedly in the five to
seven percent range which would mean
massive earnings according to The
Hollywood Reporter Downey took home
somewhere in the neighborhood of 75
million dollars for Avengers infinity
war a number that likely climbed for
Avengers endgame check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos to buy your favorite stuff
for coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]